oh hello I couldn't see you over my wide
brimmed ego you know a lot of people
have been talking about making America
great again so we decided to put
together a short list of New Year's
resolutions that might actually help
America do just that Ted define great
and while we're at it define again was
it great when we lost 280 million
dollars a day bringing Isis to Iraq or
back when black people couldn't vote or
maybe when women were out of the
workplace let's clarify in 2016 what we
actually mean stop playing the blame
game Mexicans Muslims Miley Cyrus we
tend to scapegoat groups of people in
order to avoid thinking don't do it
things are complicated and that's okay
nothing is black or white except the
song which has always been great hey hug
a Muslim with your feelings go ahead you
can do it except abortion it's been
around for hundreds of years and it's
not going away you're not a warrior for
babies you're scary you know who are
warriors for babies mothers mothers who
become mothers if and when they want to
and remember the more planned
parenthood's there are the less
abortions there are cuz that's how
sexual health works okay both locally
and nationally it can't hurt and yes you
can buy elections don't reassess your
fear level yes Isis is scary with show
are easily accessible assault rifles and
the YouTube comments section and chances
are driving while texting will get you
sooner than Isis will Americans we have
fear down and it's not that fun if we
completely freaked out every time
something scared us we'd all be rush
limbaugh and that's terrifying stop
killing unarmed black men police killed
a lot of people in 2015 but unarmed
black men are seven
times more likely than white men to die
by police just stop hey read the whole
article then share it it's hard but your
facebook credit will go through the roof
get real about poverty if you're running
for president don't pretend you're poor
or have any idea what it's like to be
poor income inequality in the US is as
high as it was just before the Great
Depression and we don't want that kind
of great again don't demonize people for
struggling in a broken system why not
help them just like your rich daddy
helped you and the number one resolution
to actually make America great again be
more like this cat even though you're
hungry look out for the little guy